[Music]
okay feel like I'm not going here you
see the difference because I just went
totally did he's gonna push me over
that's not what I'm doing
but we're not going that way so I'm
keeping that
Albert it's the same thing he's pushing
you're not going anywhere good see if
even when I get this hand right we're
not I'm not going in my place do you
understand and wick that is coupled if
he does I'm going to knock the hell out
we get it so that this is a UPS it look
where I'm thinking it you see so
extension and I that's the mind look at
the difference here the techniques
let's just look at his posture on
bounces it's pretty freakin straight up
and down on the ground you see so all
this posture can work but right into the
English not only on the Nadi's here and
then I gotta stop get frightened oh I've
no I don't mean hit it I mean watching
so I don't if I have big gaps in my
movements what's the big gap look at the
time that it takes for that time to get
there and the time that it takes you
that time that's a big gap
just rolling around so we're gonna work
on that part just on the handlebar you
see the difference
are you brought it all the way to a kind
of she'll I'm not getting it then you
grabbed it and then you're gonna do this
this one's down here just a hand
we're not doing the throw or just doing
the hand drill if you lose your balance
you lose your balance don't start
disconnecting your Center okay
[Music]
okay try it so this you're just doing a
drill now I'm lying on me no is he doing
the energy plant no he's not just he's
hanging up there so my job is to go
around
the difference
take the fulsome handout find their
Center through through through their
doll just deal with this hand you have
to find his Center no try it again what
is happening is when you come around you
see you there's no risk law is there I
mean he's not going because it hurts his
throwing inside right you have the
connection to the bottom that's what's
happening here so look how different his
body is when I go do you see that
difference he's hanging out there but
other way look his body movie what is
the other hand allows a fulcrum here you
see so I don't have to rotate this is
hiding it on the outside this hand is
just here so we're not going to do it
with the grip the hands John here it's
just here just put it right there and
now you will to move around this time
slower okay so I don't want to ground
like the technique I just want you to
hear and then you're doing the throw
just because that comes there but not to
me not it's still this hand is still
doing this thing this hands just look
like what you're doing but not amazing
you guys this is your take
my technique he's out he's out there
he's bouncing so I'm going to put go
back to this fault
okay but it's not this so I'm not risk
torquing him down
I am energetically out outer fringe go
slow with no gaps
[Music]
so we were going slow and he did he
didn't do the energy friend just
remember that
hey so that's why this technique when
you got his Center you had to do that
see that what on this one he's coming
through BC I can really just guiding it
out we'll do it like this okay so here
we are you see and I just sign it out no
you're not you're not gone I like this
okay you keep extending and extending
you